Carter
and I could tell like he's in the game
like he's in the game and
he's got this kid out of nowhere just
heckling at him and I'm just sitting
there so excited I'm asked can I yell
his name can I yell his name
and he looked up and he went like this
and I never forget about that I'll
remember the story remember the day just
just going like just going like that
[Music]
what up tomorrow how you doing happy to
have you thanks for having me you know I
am um happy to have you on the show good
to see you of course
but about maybe five days ago I realized
I'm coming to Denver to interview the
wrong person I should be interviewing
your mascot we all learned apparently
it's making like 600 000 a year did you
see that report yeah so what makes Rocky
the superior
um NBA mascot
he just gives off a lot of energy makes
half course shots backwards every time
um I actually had a really good rate
um and yeah yeah he just does a great
job great energy so do you know the man
or woman inside of Rocky okay what's he
or she like
us that's confidential really is this
top secret that's how it goes is the
identity not revealed does anyone know
rock
see I didn't know this so he's kind of
being paid to stay like Incognito all of
it together okay we'll tell Rocky I said
I got you okay I'm into I'm very into
this like mascot salary thing because I
feel like I'm doing the wrong profession
you could do it yeah like learn some
flips learn some behind the back I think
I could I could do it I'll work on it if
the Hawks uh Harry I'm very into Harry
the hog but I would come and do that
um but first off congrats I'm so happy
that you're back thank you we all saw
you on the present game against the
Thunder I'm sure the whole thing was
amazing but what moment in that game was
your highest moment uh
probably probably the halftime buzzer
um just because I wasn't thinking about
anything else except being in that mode
and trying to get a bucket which I I
ain't felt in a while so obviously
making my first basket was good
um just being out there hearing the fans
was good but uh to be in that mentality
to switch you know flip that switch was
uh it was good it was nice so just to
put into perspective for everyone so you
played basketball for the first time
since April 12 2021 nearly one and a
half years missed 100 of Denver's
regular season games 15 of Denver's
playoff games and as of today it will
have been about 540 days uh since you
played in the NBA game a lot of numbers
does it feel like it's been that long
yes
they're gonna say longer has this been a
it's been a journey you know all the
work you put in um all the detail stuff
you got to go through all the weight
room
um being away from the team watching
them do stuff not feeling like part of
it
um and then you know just focusing on on
doing your job not being able to do it
at a high level so
a lot of things go through your mind and
it definitely feels really long but
um I'm glad I put the work in and um was
able to show last night so what did you
learn about time through this process
it's got to stick with us gotta be
patient
um
really test me because there's times I
felt like I could do more but if I did
too much then the rest of the week would
be off about how how much I can do so it
got really confused not confusing but
really detailed and tedious and
um
all of my new stuff mattered so that was
that was probably the tough part knowing
that you know if I do one extra jump
today it's gonna be I'm gonna be sore
for two extra days yeah those were uh
those are hard to limit myself yeah so
how much of that really was like
balancing your limits what you want to
do what you can do what you can't do
um
plan nowadays better planning better
preparation
um
and knowing that you know the more time
passes the better I'm gonna feel so even
like you know a couple months ago I was
getting sore after I played now I'm not
as sore and I didn't see that before or
I didn't see when I couldn't go up the
stairs I didn't see when I couldn't go
down the more my first couple jumps were
in the water
um all those little stuff started to add
up and you start to see the progress and
everything starts to so you start to see
the light and everything well there were
certainly gay uh moments in that game
against the Thunder where you had to
really trust that ACL right we saw you
going one-on-one with Trey man you had
the fade away off the left leg how much
have you learned about having to trust
yourself and is that still hard uh no
it's it's pretty natural especially when
I'm doing something I love and it's
basketball's very natural to me but
um
it was the off the court stuff that was
was hard to be honest like
um
going down the stairs have a lot of
stairs in my house so like
I'm going upstairs going downstairs like
man I'm gonna be sore tomorrow if I go
up one more five stairs you know so I
was like those little stuff
um start to add up
um but once once I started to see the
progress I was on the court making jump
shots playing freely I'm starting to see
my moves work start to get my quickness
back uh everything just started flow
from there do you have to think about
going up and down the stairs now
I still do slightly yeah it's only
because I've only thought of it for so
long
um and because I feel
I'm still trying to feel the my needs
just trying to feel the grab on it you
know so it's not like crazy oh my God
the stairs but right oh no on the stairs
but it's still something that's like
okay I just gotta make sure I just go
down properly yeah yeah well because one
thing that I've kind of learned as guys
do go through certain recovery is
there's more so these moments where you
say okay I'm back or I feel better and I
wonder if a moment for you of feeling
fully returned is when you aren't
thinking about things like the stairs at
all anymore
um even the game you know if I do an
awkward movement
I don't sometimes I'm like oh I didn't
move as quick as I wanted to just for
that slight second but then another move
works or I get to where I want to and I
don't think about it anymore but it's
just for that Split Second like man this
I didn't I wasn't thinking about this
two years ago so yeah I'm just gonna
keep progressing keep getting better
yeah no I love that I saw a picture of
your dad sitting next to you on the
bench before it again and I've read a
lot about obviously how he helped mold
you into the player that you are today
that moment on the bench what were you
all talking about before the game uh I
didn't get to see him before the game so
we were just catching up real quick from
his fight
um he had a long day so he was tired but
um it was nice he just wanted to be the
farmer for his game he's been a while to
see me play and he knows where I'm
coming from so uh it's just nice to have
him in the presents so as I was getting
ready for this
um I went through some of your Twitter
likes your
second like second most recent like I'll
rephrase but it is something to the
extent of people really forgot how good
Jamal Murray is do you feel that way
that they forgot that I do I really do
um
just because I've been gone for so long
uh you know when you see like the top
top guys and there you go to try to rank
guys you know they I have been playing
so they don't rank me so like
that kind of puts in my head like okay I
got some work to do when I come back so
um
those kind of thing as you see a lot you
know people they take you out of the
categories they put someone else that
shouldn't be there and then all of a
sudden you're like non-existent because
you're not playing so
uh when I come back to play
um I want to make sure that I have that
in mind and I and I keep those notes
those mental notes just got check boxes
you know yeah because I I do think once
people get injured
there is this element of you're almost
out of the conversation and then you in
turn are probably internally struggling
with like okay do they remember that
like I'm also good I just got injured it
hasn't changed who I am as a player how
did you deal with that feeling of being
what you thought was forgotten
um honestly when you're not playing
um you just got to focus on the stuff
that is going to help you get back out
there so just putting more work in the
weight room just make sure I come back
and my legs stronger so I can trust it
better uh putting my work in my jump
shot just all those stuff while I'm
training I'm making sure like I said I'm
keeping notes and
um keeping that fire built up
um even though I can't go you know
expand it but I can have it build up in
for moments like in the games I can show
flashes and so uh what I need to do okay
so remind everyone tell us what player
what kind of player Jamal Murray is I
mean it shows for yourself
um people kind of refer to the uh the
bubble guys like I'm the same I'm the
same guy I didn't I didn't change it's
just a year later whatever two years
later so
um hopefully I can go back and do a
couple couple moves that remind them and
and put my name back on that uh back in
that pedestal yeah you know as someone
who is also in the bubble it's so funny
that we really will always refer to this
like playoffs one year as the bubble
playoffs and just how special that
moment was I mean obviously no one
wanted to be in the bubble we didn't
want the circumstances that were
happening in the world but I think that
that basketball was some of the best
basketball I will ever see for the rest
of my life for sure do you feel that way
sure I think that was the highest level
of basketball being played
um
because it was only basketball and guys
were so locked in this you know you go
to the gym you have shoot around you eat
you
play
win or lose you you're in your room and
you go back to the gym if you want some
if you want to do something you want a
hobby
you just go to the gym you have a court
time from six to nine like that was all
we did you know so I'm not really
playing cards with your teammates you
know so
um guys were just locked in I was like
we're always talking about basketball I
was talking about coverages or I was in
the gym shooting Fritos
um
so it was just that was the only thing
we're doing and that helped me for sure
because that's the kind of guy I am to
stay locked in night in night out you
know that's why I think there's this
contingent of people that try to
discredit the Lakers for winning in the
bubble saying it doesn't count there is
such a major argument to be had for it
to actually have been harder to win in
the bubble but a lot of people I think
don't really believe in the bubble
basketball have you experienced that at
all uh I've seen it you know I've seen
on Twitter people trying to understand
it but I don't I don't see it that way
as well I think it's one of the realest
possible to happen you know no I was
real basketball you know there's no fans
everything's kind of eerie in there so
you know if coach yells at you is taking
different than when fans are around and
you can't kind of get blown over stuff
like that you know so
um like I said it was really real it was
real basketball real Hoops out there
absolutely and bubble Jamal Murray was
certainly something that's very special
what do you attribute those specific
performances to
um just a lot of build up
um being mentally focused to play
um and my dad said something to me uh
I think after the
game one against Utah
and we came back
um he said every time you step on the
court you can make history so
from I don't know why I resonated but
you know from that point on when you
said that um
it just some clicked so when I when I
started to see myself do it and start to
gain the confidence in doing it
um I didn't want to lose that I just
kind of built on it and night and night
I'll built on it and then you know I
became part of the garden and that's
when uh
you know we beat you know the Jazz and
then we moved on it was the same thing
it was just like just keep that same
energy there's no need to go back and
being consistent you know just I I kind
of found something I found my routine
and I just stuck with it yeah how do you
take that same sort of mindset about
making history every time that you step
onto the court into this season
um
just using everything of
um
thought about being out
I think you have so many thoughts so
many doubts and people doubt you on top
of that and then you're not playing so
it's hard to see yourself what you can
do after that the unknown going to the
unknown you're not sure about
so for me it was just
being excited to play using my happiness
using my love for the game and I think
it'll show by itself so uh like you know
two days ago we played and
once I hit my first job I was like okay
I'm good I'm here now I can just play
freely you know I got I got the monkey
off my back now I'm just playing
basketball so once I can get those games
I get some Rhythm and uh we got a lot of
new players so you find that chemistry I
think would be fine
all right so this season what we're
gonna see from you you've never been an
All-Star no I haven't which how does it
feel hearing that but you've never been
an All-Star no I haven't
um credit though there's a lot of good
competition so
um CJ hasn't been all star either
um he's one of the toughest guys to
guard
but I do want to make All-Star I do want
to make Oster I want to have that that
title
um just something that I've never had
and I now I have two playoffs that I
missed so I just feel like you know I'm
that guy in the playoffs and my I've
always had that kind of edge so I just
need the I just need the resume to show
it now that's all and so knowing that
knowing there's some stiff competition
I'm in the westio to do that how do you
get that on your resume what will it
take for you to separate from that and
become an All-Star just being me just
being just being natural I go overthink
it
um I'm gonna get my shots do two days I
can
I can be more locked in because also
doing the bubble and that's what we had
to do so
um just taking the basketball night and
Night Out day in Day Out
um I think that's all I need to be
honest with you just more uh more
commitment
one thing that always comes up is you
and jokic and the Synergy that you all
have the great chemistry you have it's
something that's sad and thrown around
but why is it why do you think you all
have such good chemistry and has it
always been that way always been that
way we uh so we came up the bench
together my rookie years
um nerk started and then Moody and Jamir
started over me and Gary too so uh we
came off the bench together and then we
started doing the hit the post I cut and
he threw it over his head and that would
always make the Highlight for some
reason and then
when he took next spot I moved up it
just we kept that and
Yoke's a very unselfish player he just
wants to pass and get out Guys open
um and I'm just trying to make the right
play so you know we just kind of feed
off each other's energy if I'm open
there's no hesitation to pass the ball I
think a lot of a lot of teams have that
slight pause or that slight hesitation
with a slight overthinking uh the play
where for us it's just boom boom bang
somebody's open you know there's no
really
there's no there's no call for it
there's no there's no waiting around and
um it's just nice to have somebody on
the same page all the time all game no
matter the time the game was for you
know so that ease that comes with you
all is there anything that you can
compare it to
peanut butter and jelly yeah like you
just put peanut butter first and then
you put jelly on top it's just that's
just how it goes that's how people make
it you know so I feel like it's the same
thing where when we go pick and rolls
okay it's simple if the defender does
this this is what I'm supposed to do and
he knows the same way around for him so
uh we do a lot of that uh
playing with the defense and making them
make them think about how to guard us
you know and I assume that it's gotten
to the point where you also just know
what he's gonna do before he does it
you're in your spot you know where it's
coming I mean that's very very clear uh
when we watch you all play which is why
it's very exciting that you're going to
be on the court together jokic
um there's kind of a chance he could get
third MVP I think if everything goes
right do you see that if you'll catch
this yeah I mean you got me Mike Ag and
Pope
kcp
um starting five
you know that's like
he was getting tenances before imagine
you'd be shooting the the guys that you
know shoot like 40 for seven three so
he's gonna have a lot of assists this
year and uh his workload won't be as
high as
the past couple years yeah because you
are gonna come in and take a lot of that
that weight off of him what do you think
makes you all legitimate contenders this
season
uh we don't panic I think that's a big
thing during the season during the game
there's no Panic um and there's always a
sense that we can come back I know a lot
of teams know if you go down 10 15 20
points it's kind of okay we we know we
got him uh with us you know we can come
back at any time we just need a couple
baskets go in a couple stops and we're
right there with with new Energy new
life um I think the resiliency is a big
part of our team
um and knowing that we can actually get
the job done and accomplish the job so
um yeah like I said just free-flowing uh
we have a lot of fun with the game
um and we enjoy to see each other
succeed okay so watching from the
sidelines what did you learn about your
team's defense
which year
um
just need to get better just need an
improvements that's all
um
I thought we had some really good stints
at the Austin Rivers did a great job
last year trying to grow stuff uh even
when Steph scored he was right there and
and
um was disciplined
um
well I think this year we have a we have
a squad where Bruce Brown kcp is back
I'm back
um we have a lot of guys that can switch
one through five one through four and
um get some stuff so yeah yeah I know
that in the press conference you were
asked about you know when all five of
you are on the floor you beat the
Clippers you said you felt like no one
could beat you what about that moment
made you as a team feel Unstoppable and
how far is this team from that like I
said we were down 3-1 twice and it
didn't phase us like
we still knew we had to play basketball
they still had to come play the next
game
um we didn't weary from that we didn't
we didn't get uh you know you know down
or sad or feel sorry for ourselves it
was just like they gotta win one more
and then we're not gonna make it easy
for them and uh that went for both
Series so uh once we especially when you
see yourself
come back the first time you're like oh
man we did something that's never been
done around for whatever eighth time has
been done and then we did it again the
same play I was like
we have something real special you know
we got a team that can do a lot if you
just gonna have to a better start maybe
up 3-1 you know change Pace a little bit
um have better chances but yeah yeah one
thing that's very clear to me through
talking to you now but also from what
I've read is for you the mental side of
the game is probably the most important
I read a lot about your dad teaching you
all what I think you called mental Kung
Fu yes tell everybody what that means
and how that bleeds into your game
um I always try to compare it to like a
fight so I watch a lot of boxing and UFC
and if a fighter doesn't bring that
energy if he doesn't you know come
prepared he's going to get knocked out
in front of everybody in front of his
family in front of his kids in front of
the world
um and so I try to bring that same
energy to basketball where if I'm not
locked in or if I have a really slow
start or whatever
we're gonna lose and I try to have that
mentality
um
also a bounce back metallic so if you
know if team hits me first so I have a
bad really bad first half I can go and
lock and reset and then come back with
the new energy and have
how many points I want basically
um that's that mental side that's that
uh that Kung Fu that um that fighting
Spirit you know so
should I keep that on me so do you feel
like you play better when it feels like
there's more pressure yes
if if if somebody screams me hard and
hits me in my mouth I'm gonna have a
better game you know if if you're almost
making me you know go ahead shoot then
I'm like not locked in you know I'm just
kind of going through it
um so when a guy tests me or when a team
tests us or the stakes are higher or the
pressure's higher yeah I think it
definitely um raises our level of play
what I always think about is what
someone told me once they said that fear
makes the wolf bigger than he is and I
think that in a place like the Western
Conference it's a lot of wolves a lot of
teams that can look very scary
how do you know that no matter who the
opponent is what the team is the you and
your team have a chance uh because we've
done it we've seen it
um
no anybody can be anywhere in the league
but
when you when you bring
the best version of you it's hard to see
yourself lose it's hard to because you
don't say about the best version and I
know I'm gonna lose because who thinks
that they're going to lose after
bringing their best so if I know if I go
bring my best
regardless of what's happening I think
we have a chance
um and I try to feed that to the
teammates and bring the energy to the
team to the fans uh
just kind of rally them and bring that
energy but you know
not every guy has it every night so you
got to figure a way to pull it out of
them
um and always hold yourself to high
standard you know if you don't have it
you've got to find a way to get into it
whatever it is whatever's from the
halftime come just reset like it is for
me
um or whatever it is
um but yeah that's what I try to do so
when you look at this season and you
think about your goals how has goal
setting maybe changed for you for this
stretch because you're coming off of an
injury Championship well we're trying my
Championship nothing less
um
I know I'm not where I want to be yet in
terms of the the level of play but
um I feel like once we hit the stride
once we hit our rhythm
you know I feel like we'll be you know
top three
in the league you know just at the
finals
um
I just know that you can't skip you
can't skip over the finals because
there's the work has to be done uh the
preparation has to be done the progress
the ups and the Downs the diversity you
gotta go through it all before you get
there but that's where we see ourselves
is at the top yeah I mean if you talk
about playing well under pressure it
feels like a lot of pressure a lot of
expectations on this team to get it done
this time do you feel that whether it
affects you personally or not do you
feel that expectation I mean I can be an
expectation but it doesn't I don't feel
like
it gets pressure though like it's just
still something we're all trying to
everybody's trying to win a championship
good teams bad teams we're all trying to
win the championship
um
we just feel like we have the team to do
it and we'll be cutting ourselves shorts
if we if we didn't believe in it or
actually make it a goal
um so
I don't see us not making the finals
just because I know how good this team
can be you know so
there was a moment um in the piece of
the game against the Thunder where you
looked at the crowd and you said that's
what I do that's what I do what did you
want the people to feel in that moment
um like I said in that moment when
we saw there was six seconds on the
clock doesn't matter what quarter just
six seconds left and Joker's inbound the
ball and we got six seconds to go
um did like nothing else matters
everybody's waiting everybody's
expecting us to score
um
for all I'm in a different mode when I
had the ball so
uh
I felt it because I felt me and I
haven't felt me in a while so when I
felt me I was like okay
let me let me let me bring up let me let
me bring them on in you know yeah let me
bring a lot in yeah
um
it was a first taste and everything but
it was just nice to to have that uh that
energy back in the building you know
it's been a while because see I thought
you were gonna say that was your
favorite
place that really meant something to you
because you were feeling the energy and
feeling back to yourself when you said
that yeah yeah and that's six seconds I
was I was the Jamal that everybody knows
you know and
and I wasn't shy being shy about it you
know so but what has that process been
like just generally like coming back to
yourself you know you're describing it
as
I am now what I have been which would
imply that for these past you know years
you haven't been that because you
haven't been playing has there been any
sort of
I guess thoughts about your identity and
what it means with or without basketball
uh
I just feel like I just need to see
myself do it
um to have that confidence to shake the
doubt um shake the unknown about what's
gonna happen after I come back you know
so
uh
just being in that moment being locked
in
um
feeling the energy feeling the
confidence of myself like I haven't felt
no you go and practice you hit a couple
shots it's whatever as practice but if
you go in the arena and actually doing
the game and everybody sees what you're
doing
um you get that confidence back it only
takes one one play to have to to spark
it back up again so like I said once I
had that
um I could have easily just shot it
regularly I just went off the back
because that's just I just do stuff like
that I just that's just what I am so
um it was just nice to bring the energy
back in the building see it believe it
and look forward to doing it again you
know for sure so another reason I was
really happy to talk to you is because I
want to get your thoughts on analytics
and basketball I know obviously the
nuggets are big into that uh yogic big
into that one of the big reasons he won
MVP he was just leading like every
advance that category I'm a voter I
voted for yoga to get it congrats to him
how do you feel about how it has invaded
basketball because you know on Twitter
there's this contingent of people that
are into the numbers then there's the
like he got that dog in their Twitter
and they'd go in for the eye test where
do you fall
uh my fall I feel I feel I feel you know
uh there's gonna be bad shots in the
game there's gonna be bad takes in the
game bad decisions everybody's gonna do
that but
to
take out the mid-range shot because it's
not a good shot it's it's kind of it's
kind of corny honestly I only like that
like the rose is one of the best to do
it
um pump vacant guys putting them in foul
trouble again to the free throw and
getting himself in Rhythm like there's
so much more details than just what the
point actually
means you know
um so that's that's my take on there's
so there's if you go for a game winner
I'd rather take a mid-range than a three
just it's just a he's naturally easier
shot and I can stop on a dime I can step
back and still be
in a close close space close to the
basket like there's so many different
things that can happen
um just playing off that mid region
that's just one part of the analytics
that's just the mid-range that we're
talking about you know there's so many
different aspects of the analytics that
uh gets kind of buried yeah because I
mean okay I like it I get it I think
that it has certainly enhanced the game
shown things that work and things that
don't but sometimes we get too caught up
in it we are losing a lot of the stuff
that we love about the game too so I
just wonder how we can continue to have
that balance as the game progresses
because I don't know if there's that
balance right now I think you just gotta
understand somebody's game that's the
biggest thing you gotta understand what
the capability capable of doing and what
they want to do like I'm not going to
tell Joker no don't shoot a mid-range
because right it's the bad shot you know
that's his game is he makes that and
that's what wins his games so I think
you gotta look at the wins and the dubs
instead of the analytics all the time
yeah I actually had a conversation with
Jamar about that and I asked him if
there if he ever felt any sort of
pressure to change what his game is
because the game has gone away from what
he is excellent at and he said you
almost have to have this resolve that if
I know I'm the best at doing this thing
why would I ever change it and there's
going to be so many places you go where
they want you to change want you to
Trend towards whatever the popular thing
is but you're actually ruining what got
you to that space But it's difficult I
think to you know to stay there when
you're seeing other things it's like
it's like going to
um making it to the league and then they
try to change your shot it's like well I
made I made it I made it to leave by
shooting my shot that's basically yeah
the meaning of it so like when you said
that it's kind of resonated no
absolutely so then what would you say to
people that maybe don't get why maybe
jokic got the MVP over someone like
embiid what makes jokic so special
besides the numbers I mean what
the amount of possessions and games
throughout the seasons throughout two
years of him winning MVPs
it's crazy if you actually go and watch
the games and you watch him
he's got a guy on him
Defender coming from here sometimes
Defender coming from here he's able to
look this way and throw a pass and he's
got three guys on him like it's not easy
it's not just because he's
passing the ball or he's not doing too
much work like he's creating everything
for us literally everything so
uh to watch him do that possession after
possession to the playoffs like it's it
was pretty incredible and to have the
consistency to do it is another thing
um and I think I don't think anybody
else should have won it over over yolk I
really don't you could argue that it's
maybe even like a little underrated what
he was doing because so much of it was
just him doing it yes yes yeah very do
you oh go ahead I'll just think of uh
the confidence he got in doing it
getting double teamed and still throwing
no looks and making crazy plays and like
I said having the confidence to you know
do a one leg off the backboard like it
takes a lot of self-trust to to do that
and when you even being doubted you know
how did your appreciation for him change
watching and not playing with him
you learn a lot picked up a lot of
tricks in the post
um
uh
but yeah it's just beautiful to see you
know you almost just can't wait to see
what he's going to do it's just that you
know in our moment I'm watching them
play and uh knowing that he's not being
selfish with either he's really just
trying to win the game and and look for
you and look to make plays so
um it's a joy to watch
uh so versatile and everybody talks
about how he's not that good on defense
he's got great hands though he's got
great hands he's got great anticipation
he reads the game well good on angles
like
um he's just a well-rounded player
overall you know no I mean I I love
watching him play I agree with you I
think that he deserved it doesn't be
peace like I said I voted I'm with it
I'm into all of it I voted too uh you're
like he is my pick
um there's so many just random topics
that I want to talk to you about because
I've actually never interviewed Jamal
before
um and one of those things is when you
had 48 points and you wanted to get 50.
awesome yes and you took the shot
I am not opposed to this it was a very
polarizing moment after you've done it
where do you fall on it do you think
it's disrespectful to take that last
shot
I mean I don't know
I don't know it's so far gone now it's
like why does it even matter but oh it
will happen again not with you but if
this will always be thing I'm like if I
want to get 50
scoring this is not me disrespecting
your team it's that I just I want my 50.
here's here's what I would have done I
would have shot it to make it I think I
think I just shot it expecting to make
it because I was
I was making so many shots that night
but
I really just kind of put it up in a way
I felt like if I really shot it to shoot
and I didn't hesitate then I think I
would have a different take on it so
okay yeah and your take now is I don't
really don't care yeah whether you hate
it or not that was five six years ago
like yeah I mean I'm I'm missing I'm
team Jamal on this I don't think it was
that big of a deal but it's not as bad
as whatever I don't think anyone's mad
anymore but in that time I remembered
Twitter really going back and forth
should you allowed to do this I don't
think it's that big of a deal but
haven't talked to so I wanted to ask you
about that too
um I also want to talk to you about you
meditating I read that that is something
that you do every day not anymore but
it's a big part of my preparation for
games okay can you walk me through it
just being honest with yourself
um
you know as some people find it weird
and it is weird but when you really look
at yourself in the mirror and
um
have an honest conversation it's hard to
make excuses for yourself later on
so
if I say just a quick example if I say
you know I'm really tired
I really don't want to work out in the
morning or I really don't want to work
out later
um I just want to do whatever
and then I go to the mirror and I say
yeah I really don't want to do this and
then all this stuff comes in we're like
I'm telling myself this it's not like
someone else is telling me so like
it's hard for me to say actually yeah
just don't go because I'm saying I'm
telling myself I should have gone you
know and then if I don't go it's like
well no one else is limiting me but me
now so I try to keep that in uh in my
head all the time where I can I can't go
back on myself if I say I'm gonna go in
the morning I can't just make them
excuse myself and not go because then
I'm only cheating myself you know yeah
so I'll try to keep that yeah you don't
want to be the thing that stops you no
no because there's not really an excuse
unless something happens where I got an
appointment I gotta I can't make it cool
but
when I say I'm going to do something I
try to actually follow through so that I
don't go back on my word
on my own word for the most part yeah
have you read The Four Agreements
in that book it's just
it's just things that they say everyone
should live by is being impeccable with
your word holding yourself to the things
that you say
um and it just made me think about it
when you say that do you do any
visualization with your meditation oh
yeah I mean before every game I try to
visualize the game and how it's going to
go or or what I want to do or just the
energy I want to bring that's the main
thing is
what energy am I going to bring because
people are watching my teammates
watching they're feeding off me I'm the
point guard I'm calling the plays I'm
leading the team so I don't want to have
my energy down or off or unpredictable
or just not there in the moment
um I want to bring a certain energy
where they look at their point guards
look at the leader as as he's ready to
go whether he misses whether he has a
bad game he's he's there for the right
reason he's doing it for the right
reason so
um I try to like I said to the fight I
can't just go in the fight and and not
bring it you know you got to bring it so
especially when you got a teammate
watching you and you got young guys
watching you and I got my little brother
watching me you know I try to uh show
the right things yeah
first regular season game what will you
visualize
I feel like it's just gonna be natural I
think the first time I touched the court
was the big one I think that would be
visualize that day uh just making my
first shot I think that's why it took me
so long to make it my first shot Ah
that's right because I would think about
it the whole time
um
even when I got to the freeze line
I shot the technical like the crowd was
cheering I was already smiling I'm like
I already know I'm Gonna Miss This I'm
just not here right now I'm just too
happy and then once I went to the bench
and settle down relax my neighbors got
calm focus on the game then I made my
shot and everything was just slowing up
that yeah okay regular season should be
Reckless season should be I should be I
should be going by then yeah I mean I
also think this is great news for
nuggets fans because it feels like for
you you did just needed that game oh
yeah check my own box yeah yeah it was
about your boxes yeah I just need to
check my list and um get that game under
my belt and just just feel it you know
and then after that I can figure out my
rhythm and my pace and all that all that
stuff's easy to figure out once you plan
but I just gotta get that monkey on my
back I love that and I also hope fans
really do understand just the mental
fortitude that it takes to even have
gone on to the court that day wanting to
make that first shot trusting your body
knowing that you're ready I think all of
those things are kind of underestimated
when a player is making that return I
think that when I think about Dane
coming back Kawhi coming back been
coming back all of these people it's not
just about that physical element of
stepping under the court it's what you
have to tell yourself on the court what
you had to say before you stepped on the
court a lot of things really go into it
that I don't know if that's always
that's always appreciated what do you
think people don't fully understand
about recovery or what did you have to
learn about recovery that you didn't
know
um
I mean I've been hurt before but I've
never been out like that
um
and
like in the playoffs against Golden
State they wanted me to come back and I
was training to come back I was ramping
up I was doing more
but I wasn't close
mentally to play like I wasn't
navigating screens was hard now you want
me to go and navigate a screen with
Steph like it's just I'm just not there
yet you know so
um the mental side was uh was harder and
I'm good with the mental side but it was
just a lot
tougher and the duration of it and the
amount of thought that you put into it
and the amount of doubt that happens
then you see other people doubt and then
you don't know what's gonna happen
because you're not playing so like
there's so many different things
circling your head
um
I just had to stick to myself and know
that even though I want to play my
passion comes out I want I want to be
there for the team
like I just there's so many parts of the
game where I wasn't I just couldn't do
it I wasn't I wasn't there yet so now
that I look
whatever six months later
I'm in a completely different space than
I was before and now when I look here
I'm like man I thank God I didn't play
it you know like it was just you know it
finally comes into context and finally
comes out
um How It Should so yeah it was just
nice to see it through and get healthy
and not have any uh any regretable plan
you know
I think you're right you made the
smartest decision but in that moment how
hard was it to have to say
no I can't play very hard I went to my
dad and said I wanted to play that's the
thing like I was I wanted to play and I
if if I
stop training like I wanted to play and
I would have been ready to play so I had
to keep that that thing going where okay
I'm he's trained to come back a train
and come back where they're coming back
or not he's training to come back
um
so yeah once once I said I wasn't come
back it was like okay I'm not going to
the weight room I'm not I'm not shooting
it was kind of like you know meant to
relax I just kind of relaxed and chilled
because I knew I wasn't going to play so
I'm happy I uh I kept the training
like it should have been yeah but that's
the way I had asked you like what you
learned about time like what your
relationship is with time now because
you have to give time time you know and
sometimes we just think that because we
want something it'll happen but so much
of everything is a process and having
things go in the way that they should
which I'm sure you had to learn through
this just because you won something
doesn't mean it's the right thing for
sure you can do so sure I'm sure you
learned a lot about yourself too through
this when I um when I
said I wasn't going to play
it was like coming down from a high or
something like I
went into a dark spot like I this is
what I've been working for this is what
I've been training for so I've been
trying to get healthy for
Blood Sweat and Tears days I didn't want
to do it pain soreness
um all that stuff and then it's not to
not get a reward of playing like that
really sucks so
I definitely hit it down after I knew it
wasn't going to play and it was like a
buildup okay now I gotta bring my I
gotta fix my energy to
go back and hit training again and and
go with the same mentality a better
mentality um
now that I look him in such a better
spot it's like
everything happens for a reason you know
yeah just worked out the way it should
yeah because playing in that probably
was like the light at the end of the
tunnel but it was light yeah that's
taken away it's just tunnels you've got
more to go he's like yeah that was the
thing is I was hoping to see myself make
it back on the court and then when I
didn't I was like man I got I gotta wait
a whole another thing I gotta have a
whole different view on it you know it
was just it was a lot mentally to get
through that you said that it was a dark
spot for you what do you mean by that
um
it's just like looking forward to
something you've always looked forward
to and then actually putting the work in
for it and then not seeing the reward
out of it was like
man I was thinking this is I've already
been through nine ten months of of not
doing it
um it's hard to see another another five
after that
um
that was a tough part going through the
summer the beginning of the summer at
least and uh
uh not having the feeling of playing
because the longer I'm not playing the
more around the Rhythm I am just the
more it takes for me to get back in the
room so um
so yeah
more bad days or good days
uh that's a good question
um definitely more good days definitely
more good days but those bad days can
can really change your thinking or
change a person
um
I have somebody tell me the fear of the
unknown is as is strong because you're
adding
you can add whatever you want in that
time frame so if I don't know I didn't
know it was coming back I didn't know
how I was going to go I didn't know when
I was coming back
the situation I was going to be in all
that was was fearful all that was
unknown
um
and then I didn't come back and say okay
it sucks but
at least
I can I'm in control of the next five
months I'm in control of how prepared I
am my Readiness my focus I have a I have
an opportunity to
to remodel my my mentality going into
the next season you know yeah it's not
I'm not going into the fire of the
playoffs and got to deal with whatever
it is I'm going to a regular season
where I have a fresh start and a new
beginning almost yeah
yeah so you talk about comparing you
know going on to the court to fight yep
you talk about this mental kung fu what
fighter are you Jamal Murray was a
fighter who are you who embodies Jamal
Murray
um it would definitely be a fighter with
confidence of most confidence
uh flare someone who's exciting to watch
um
I don't talk a lot I don't talk crazy so
I don't I don't want to say something
that talks crazy uh you wait you're not
a trash talker at all
are you I mean depends on the situation
I do not believe you but okay when I'm
when I'm in mode when I'm when I'm in
mode I'm definitely a different person
yeah I'm not even
I'm not even thinking of this person as
a person to me I'm just I'm just
thinking about what I got to do
um in mode okay mode locked in your
Alter Ego basically I called my yeah
does your ego have a name
nah you got a name you got a name just
quiet assassin quiet assassin I'm into
it uh I don't know what fighter I would
be though I'm getting like kind of some
Bruce Lee Vibes because this is very
mental It Feels Like For You Bruce Lee
water yeah yeah flow adjust yeah that's
me right there yeah that's a good one
yeah oh yeah it's like he's it's for
sure some some Bruce Lee going on
um a couple more people before we finish
I was watching an interview you did and
you said something that I just I just
resonated with me a lot and I think
probably resonates with a lot of
basketball players you said one of the
hardest parts is being you when you're
someone else to everybody
what did you mean by that
um
just being true to yourself is
tough sometimes when other people think
they know you or think that you should
be a certain way or think that your
situation is different you know than it
really is
um
I don't know that kind of goes for a lot
of things uh
like if I go to store and I I'm just at
the gas station I'm just trying to get
some milk
like people pulling out cameras and
phones and
um
it's hard to
be myself knowing that they're looking
at me in a different light so like
even if I'm frustrated if I'm annoyed or
if I'm I don't have it that day like
it's hard to it's hard for them to see
that you know so I try to
I do a good job of holding my temper but
I definitely have my days where I'm just
like man this guy does not
respect my space at all yeah you know so
I think that goes on the court as well
it's like why isn't he doing this it's
like this just that's not how that's not
how things are working right now it's
just you know you're looking from the
outside in basically
um
and you got to stick to the what's going
on on the actual Insight that's all just
staying true to your identity for sure
we just had Jason Tatum on the show and
he talks about this and one thing I
asked him is like what have you had to
sacrifice to be Jason Tatum and he's
like really everything my time my space
yep privacy he's like anything that I do
is a thing like he the reason we started
talking about it was the photo of him
and KD and then everyone's like oh my
God is Jason trying to get Katie he's
like nope actually we're just working
out you know and it's like you almost
can't do anything without people putting
things on you and there's not really any
Grace I think that is given to NBA
players people see an image to see a
video and they have decided that that's
who you are or that's what you're doing
in that moment so how do you deal with
still being you well also understanding
what you said that there are other
people that see us things too uh I think
I just I do a good job of reading people
and I don't get too upset so if if they
look at me like if they're really
excited or if whatever it is I just try
to keep that in mind I don't wanna
I don't want to come off wrong or uh
you know just be rude or anything or
just throw them off because I'm having
an off day you know I try to at least
they're happy they're this is this is
something I've worked for my whole life
and I remember seeing Vince
um
as a young kid and I tell the story
every during every interview but
um I was in the stands as a young kid my
favorite player we were in the full
purple and gold with the shoes and
everything full everything you're vinced
out fenced out headband not even neat I
didn't like wearing Heavens but I worry
just cause events um
and I yelled his name as as
um
as hard as I could
and I said this Carter
and I could tell like he's in the game
like he's in the game and
he's got this kid out of nowhere just
heckling at him and I'm just sitting
there so excited I'm asked can I yell
his name can I yell his name
and he looked up and he went like this
and I'll never forget about that I
remember the story remember the day just
just going like just going like that
um
so when I see a kid or I see a fan even
adults it's kind of weird with adults
because it's like you should understand
like just give me you know just take it
just chill yeah chill out we're grown
but when I see a kid at least
um with that kind of excitement like I
don't I don't I just drop everything you
know I don't have to carry that with me
when I see a kid
um so happy because that that moment
changed my life that moment changed my
outlook my
um perception on people
um all that stuff so just by when I was
six years old I remember that that
changed me so I try to have that same
thing where if a kid sells yell
something
um I can give that same vibe that he
Vince gave me you know and you know you
certainly have I'm sure given that to so
many kids that are going to remember
that specific moment okay one last one
for you because I know we need to wrap
can we have on this have you on the show
without asking you about games I know
that you love you're a gamer
um NBA 2K before you were on the Nuggets
what team did you play with
I use LeBron a lot
I used
um Eddie House from Miami oh okay
torch in people with Eddie house I'm
talking about like when I was young I
was not expecting you to say that but
okay Michael red okay all these guys yes
yes I love it I I've been gained I've
been playing 2K since like 2K3 so I've
been playing I've been playing Corey
mcgetty like he used to be a slasher
just Unstoppable
um Eddie house was like was a was
definitely one of my favorites no I love
this is actually the second Michael red
mentioned DeMar DeRozan also mentioned
Michael Redd is someone who gave him
some really good advice so he's gotten
some love on the show and lastly I know
you've talked about your rating before
they came out you said that you should
have at least been I think you said an
88 you said at least but what are you
I don't know I think I'm 85 or 86. okay
I think something like that so we're
gonna get that out absolutely yes yeah
absolutely it's got to change yes I love
that you heard that Ronnie wherever
you're at Ronnie knows I told him like
he is here uh no Jamal you were a
pleasure thank you for doing this I'm so
happy that you're back we're all excited
to watch you and I'll have a beautiful
season I appreciate it thank you of
course
[Music]